What's up?
I'd like to start the interview with asking you a couple of English questions which have been nagging me for years.
Okay.
How do you say "kokuteri" in English?
I would say probably the first word that comes to mind is "thick".
Yes, but thick?
Thick sort of ends up being like "toro minoaru",...
...or like "torotoro", "dorodoro".
You know, as we were just talking a few minutes ago about "kaori" or "fumi"...
...and then when I'm explaining something to someone in English about something that smells good,...
...I almost invariably switch into Japanese.
Because "fumi" and "kaori" is a lot better than smell or...
Better than saying smell or aroma, which just doesn't seem to give the right nuance.
Right.
"Bouquet" really is almost exclusively to either wine or something that's particularly aromatic.
I think whereas it doesn't fit into just sort of the main usage of the word "bouquet".
And I think "bouquet" also, you think of something sort of almost blossoming in smell.
Whereas "fumi" is more like, you can almost see the flavor coming out of your nose.
You know, to me Japanese is funny. As I get better at it,...
...you know, you got sweeping little words that help to explain a specific thing.
And "fumi" is the taste of the wind.
So it's, you know the "kanji"?
It's a little bit more nebulous than just smell.
Right.
And it has more of a taste sense, a flavor sense.
And then once again, to explain the kokuteri,...
...I think the biggest problem is that if we were really to delve into this...
You know, this is the big problem between Japanese and English.
There isn't just one word.